so this button was excavated from lot 12
of roosevelt park yesterday and we
couldn't quite see the design on it and
when we removed the dirt we saw that
there was an anchor there but we
couldn't quite see the details of the
rope and the construction design of the
button so the button is now sitting on
the platform of this instrument which is
called the patch that's its nickname
it's a polynomial texture mapping
instrument and it collects a series of
40 pictures with the light shining upon
the object from different angles and
then we upload those images into the PTM
viewer and we're able to move the light
around the object and see the relief
from different angles in the details of
the finer details of the object beneath
the corrosion and on the surface of it
most of the metal artifacts that we find
here in Detroit are corroded because the
sub surfaced is exposed to quite a bit
of moisture so even objects that are 100
years old 10-2 corrode fairly quickly in
the ground so this is sometimes the only
way we can see the original surfaces of
the objects can you go back a little bit
there's there's a kind of depressed rim
here around the button and some of it
may even have small fine textural relief
around it some molding Justin ridges
there maybe I'm pulling the light around
in a circle you can see the lights kind
of moving it doesn't there's writing up
there when you go further up to the
right there polynomial texture mapping
is used fairly commonly in the museum
world our colleagues at the university
of chicago have an instrument that does
this but there's is a hugely expensive
larger version of this but they both do
the same thing they might be looking at
ancient sculptures egyptian sculptures
that are on a much larger scale but this
serves the purpose is that we need to
use it for in-house then it's extra cool
because the students built it and there
have a vested interest in using it rope
is going the opposite way around banker
and it's like crossing on the top here
and i'm in this one it's crossing
underneath so that's why i think it
might not actually be a military button
but this is just a really small sample
of military buttons so maybe it's a
replica of a military button mm-hmm